Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Decent. I'm your host as always Ricardo Loops. And
today I'm joined by Doctor Nicola Rayani. She is
Professor of Evolution and Behavior at Univer at University
College London. Her research considers the evolution of cooper
operation in nature. She was elected Fellow of the
Royal Society of Biology in 2019. And we're going
to talk today about her first book, The Social
Instinct How co-operation Shaped the world. So Nicola, welcome
to the show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Thanks very much for the invite. And uh yeah,
I've been looking forward to joining you.
OK, great. So let me first ask you since
this is a book basically about uh our societies
evolved about sociality. Why do you begin the book
by going all the way down to the cellular
level?
Well, I think it's kind of interesting to start
there because the book has the book has a
very obvious structure. So it starts very small, thinking
about co-operation that uh happens inside the bodies of
multicellular organisms. And then it in each part of
the book, I zoom out a level and think
about the evolution of families and then the evolution
of co-operation beyond the family group. And finally, in
the last part of the book, I talk about
the evolution of societies and large scale co-operation. Um
The reason that I wanted to have that structure
is that I think um for people who maybe
don't know a lot about cooper operation or who
haven't, you know, studied it in much detail. It
would be quite easy to assume that cooper operation
was just something that happens between individuals. So it's
some kind of behavior that you see individuals doing
and that's observable in some way in the real
world. Uh And I don't think it's as widely
appreciated that actually every multicellular being on earth, every
living multicellular organism, whether it's a plant or an
animal or, or a fungi is actually created through
co-operation and it's created through genes cooperating with one
another and cells cooperating with one another to um
form this collective that we call an organism or
an individual. And the reason that I wanted to
uh have this structure and to think about this
sort of this, this cooper operation at these, the
lowest levels if you like at the lowest levels
of organization is because it helps, it helps us
to realize as we move through the book, these
very general principles that underpin co-operation at all levels
of life, whether we're talking about genes cooperating inside
bodies or ants cooperating inside a a colony or
people cooperating inside a society. There are some kind
of fundamental general principles that emerge at all these
levels of life. And that's why I wanted to
start with this perspective of the understanding the individual
as a feat of cooper operation. Um TO try
to bring out those commonalities and to surprise people
in a way,
right? And why do you decide to focus on
cooper operation? Because for example, we could also have
focused on competition. So why cooper?
Well, for me, co-operation and competition are two sides
of the same coin. Um So in, I think
one of the big misunderstandings in some ways about
the selfish gene, the book by Richard Dawkins, which
is 45 years old now is that it predicts
is that selfish genes would predict selfish behavior and
that we would only find selfish genes inside the
bodies of the most selfish or uh nefarious individuals.
And in fact that has been that is a
misconception and continues to be a misconception of what
that gene eye's view perspective of evolution is about.
And Dawkins himself noted in his book that in
many ways, the most effective ways for a gene
to ensure that copies of itself find their way
into future generations is to co-operate. And through this
lens, we can see that co-operation is often a
selfish or a self interested strategy. And so for
me, I see focusing on co-operation is in some
ways, it just depends how you want to view
it, you can view cooper operation as being a
form of competition if you like, even though people
don't often think of it that way. So I
wouldn't necessarily say that my book is only about
cooper operation. It's about how cooper operation is often
an effective way to compete or to prosper.
So when trying to understand the evolution of human
co-operation, what would be the best uh models? I
mean, in terms of other species to, to which
we should compare humans? I mean, would it be
the most closely related to us, the other great
apes or others?
So I think this is a really interesting question
and this is one, this kind of question is
one that's actually underwritten lots of my own academic
research because many of the species that I've worked
on outside of my research on humans have been
species that not only are not very closely related
to us on the tree of life, but they're
species that people probably have never even heard of.
So things like a pied babbler, which is a
bird that lives in family groups in, in the
Kalahari desert or the cleaner fish, which is a
fish that lives on coral reefs in the in
throughout the Indo Pacific. And one of the general
um underlying themes of the research that I've done
when I've compared the behavior of nonhuman species with
what we see in humans and in particular, the
social behavior and the co-operative behavior is that often
we can find striking similarities in the kinds of
behavioral outcomes that are achieved by humans and by
quite distantly related species like meerkats and hide babblers
and cleaner fish. Even though we don't, we're not
closely related to these species. Uh And one of
the key points in some ways is this idea
that often we might get to the same behavioral
destination as another species. So to give an example,
one of the behaviors that humans are famous for
is teaching and we tend to think of teaching
as being, you know, a quintessentially human activity. Um
And when we, when people started looking for examples
of teaching in the animal world, in the nonhuman
world, they instinctively looked for it first in species
like chimpanzees and gorillas and the other great apes.
But we didn't find those examples of teaching in
those species. And in fact, the first species where
we found an example of teaching was an ant.
And the second example was a meerkat. And so,
and the third example actually was a work that
I did, which was on pied babblers. One of
the really interesting things. And one of the main
messages in my book is that often we can
find that humans and nonhuman species can get to
the same behavioral destination. So we see these commonalities,
for example, in the fact that we teach, but
so do meerkats and so do ants and so
do pried babblers, but we get there via a
quite different cognitive journey to these other species. And
so the kind of cognition that supports teaching in
humans probably involves the ability to understand what a
pupil knows some kind of mind reading or what
psychologists call theory of mind. Whereas in species like
ants and babblers and meerkats, we don't think there's
that sort of cognition is happening at all to
facilitate teaching. And instead the teaching behavior is achieved
by our different cognitive route. And so I think
often we can find similarities in the behavior we
observe between humans and other species in the behavioral
outcomes. And we ought to look for similarities and
behavioral outcomes where the ecology is likely to favor
those kinds of behaviors. And that won't always be
in our closest living relatives that won't always be
in species like the chimpanzees and the other great
apes. But even when we do find those behavioral
similarities, what we then also have to ask is,
well, how does the cognition supporting those behaviors differ?
And that's really where I think we start to
see points of divergence between humans and other species,
which is not so much what we do. But
it's a, it's about how we do it and
it's about how we get there cognitively.
So when talking about the evolution of co-operation, particularly
with evolutionary biologists, people bring to the table evolved
mechanisms like kin selection, reciprocal altruism group selection even
so Uh I I mean, do you think that
any one of these is uh enough to explain
the evolution of co-operation or should we unders try
to understand different aspects of co-operation uh how they
evolve via one of these evolved mechanisms? And I
mean, particularly group selection because that's a very controversial
topic among evolutionary biologists. I mean, what do you
think about it?
So I think there is this sort of pervasive
assumption in a lot of the human evolution literature
that the two key mechanisms that support co-operation are
either kin selection, meaning just that you help your
relatives because you share copies of their genes. And
that's another way to get copies of your genes
into the next generation or it's reciprocal altruism. And
there is a kind of, there has been at
least an assumption in the literature that if you
can't explain co-operation, either with kin selection or with
reciprocal altruism, then we should, then we should bring
in group selection as the alternative explanation. And I
don't, I don't fully subscribe to that view. So
I think that kin selection is probably the most
important mechanism for explaining the breadth of co-operation that
we see on earth. So most of the co-operation
we see in um humans but also in nonhuman
species occurs within the confines of family groups. And
there is no coincidence that we see co-operation in
families because there's just a much bigger incentive to
help individuals who share copies of the, the same
genes that you have. And so if you were
going to say which which of these evolutionary mechanisms
has the most potential for explaining most cases of
co-operation that we see on earth. I think in
selection probably explains most of the examples we see
particularly in nonhuman species. But when we look at
between unrelated individuals where we know that kin selection
can't be at work. I think it's very short
sighted to assume that the only other mechanism at
our disposal to explain this co-operation is reciprocal altruism.
And we know that there are many, many mechanisms
that can support co-operation between non relatives, um things
like punishment and um reputation based partner of choice
or concern for reputation. And so I don't think
we necessarily have to reflexively decide that it's either
con selection or it's reciprocal altruism or else let's
bring in group selection. Um So I think there
are multiple mechanisms that are really important for understanding
how co-operation evolves. Um Interdependence is arguably even more
important than reciprocal altruism in a lot of cases
where individuals have a stake in one another's fitness.
And so they're incentivized to help their interaction partners,
even if there's no uh no scope for repayment
from those partners. I think now we there are
lots of mechanisms we know about that can support
cooper operation and group selection is just one of
those and arguably the least parsimonious given what we
know about how evolution works
and what are families from an evolutionary perspective?
So a family, I think a family is a
special kind of social group. So it's a stable
social group, um obviously usually comprised of genealogical relatives.
Um In our own case, I think we tend
to think of families as being nuclear families, mum,
dad and the kids. Um BUT in fact, nuclear
families are a bit of an outlier for in,
in nature, but also in our own species. The
nuclear family is a bit of an outlier when
you consider our long history on this planet. And
also if you think outside of the western model
of society and look more broadly at other cultures,
the western model of the nuclear family is really
quite unusual and where we see family life in
humans, but also in other species, which are often
called co-operative breeders, family tends to be based on
a more extended notion of family. So you often
have um a breeding pair or the mother and
father and then several other individuals, relatives who might
live in the same stable social group and might
all contribute to raising offspring within that group.
So since you mentioned the nuclear family, and because
this ties back to questions that people nowadays are
discussing particularly in politics about the role that the
nuclear family plays and how important it is. I
mean, since we have such high degrees of cooper
breathing, particularly looking cross culturally and back in time,
I mean, uh I is it really that important
for Children to have at home, both a mother
and a father or, I mean, is it at
least one of them essential or could, can they
be replaced by other people or other? I mean,
family and perhaps friends and perhaps even in the
case of, of modern societies, other people from certain
institutions.
So I think this is one question which has
been massively thrown into sharp relief by the pandemic
that we're currently experiencing. And for anyone like me
who has, who lives in a western nuclear family,
where you have a mum and dad and Children
at home, the experience of having school closures and
the usual um sources of help, the way that
we outsource our childcare to these institutionalized um forms
of childcare has really exposed just how dependent we
are on help to in order to be able
to successfully raise offspring. And I think this is
a, there is a more general point here like
you said, which is that there is an ideology
and it is an ideology in the West that
the mother is the, she ought to be the
exclusive caregiver for her offspring and is the irreplaceable
caregiver for her offspring. And that if a mother,
for example, outsources that childcare by sending her child
to nursery when they're too young or, or outsourcing
it to other forms of, of institutionalized child, then
she might be wreaking some kind of emotional damage
or harm onto her child. And I think that
that view is pernicious, not just because it enforces
a patriarchal norm of women staying at home to
look after Children and, and, and these things, but
because it actually has no bearing on what we
know about the reality of how humans evolved, which
is that we evolved in extended family groups where
Children would have been raised by many, many different
individuals and not just by the mother. And often
not even the mother would not even have been
necessarily the primary caregiver. Um For a lot of
the time Children would have been raised by their
older siblings, by their grandparents, by various other adults
in around aunts, uncles and so on. Um And
this idea that Children need to form this bond
with one individual in order to develop a secure
attachment and that if that is somehow disrupted, that
the child will go on to have emotional and
behavioral problems, really has no empirical support. And also
is just not in keeping with our view of
with our, our understanding of how humans evolved. And
the fact that Children have always grown up being
looked after by multiple different caregivers. Um And the
reason we probably don't, we have the, we're able
to have these nuclear families or we're able to
persist in these nuclear families in the West is
that we outsource that childcare nowadays to these various
institutions. And that's how, you know, that's we out,
we send our Children to school, you know, things
like this. So I think it's in some ways,
one of the messages in the book that I
write in in the chapter on childcare is that
the an evolutionary perspective would suggest that it's completely
fine to send your Children to daycare. That's a,
a very normal situation for a young human child
to be immersed in, to be surrounded by other
Children and to be looked after by multiple different
caregivers, not just the mother.
So another question since we have so much cooperating
co-operative breeding in humans and in the case of
men, uh we have paternity, uncertainty. Why is it
that paternal investment in humans evolved? I mean, I
I'm asking you that also because many times people
say, and I'm not completely sure if this is
true that in comparing to other species, human males
are sort of outliers in how much they invest
in their Children.
So you're right that humans are a bit unusual
as far as mammals go in, that males are
involved often in helping to raise the offspring. That's
not a human, that's not a universal. So there
is some cross cultural variation in how involved fathers
are with raising their offspring and sometimes sometimes fathers
aren't really involved at all. There are some societies
like the Da Toga in Tanzania where men are
really not involved at all in raising their offspring.
And there are other societies um like for example,
the, the matrilineal society called the um Mosi society
in China, where men actually have much more to
do with their sister's Children than they do with
their own Children. So they're much more involved in
raising their nieces and nephews than they are in
raising their own um offspring. So it's not a
hu it's not a universal, but there is a
general pattern that, that human males are typically more
involved in raising offspring than the average male mammal
is. Um AND you mentioned paternity uncertainty. And I
think for humans actually, as far as uh again
in relation to other mammal species, paternity uncertainty for
humans is typically relatively low. So our best evidence,
even though it's very difficult to be certain, indicates
that humans probably evolved um to uh uh to
be socially and sexually monogamous females probably weren't mating
with multiple males at the same time. And we
can infer this based on looking at things like
relative, the size of the testicles relative to the
body size in humans and other ape species. The
idea being that if females are what we call
promiscuous in that they mate with multiple males, um
during a single Easter cycle, males ought to grow
bigger balls because they need to produce more sperm
to be able to compete in sperm competition with
other males. Human males, uh their rela their testy
size relative to their body size is much closer
to what we would expect. Um IF humans mating
system as ancestrally was more at the monogamous end
of the scale. And that implies that a relatively
high degree of paternity certainty in humans compared to
something like a chimpanzee, where females are much more
promiscuous and do mate with many males in the
group um within a single Easter cycle. Uh And
so, I think, um in part, we can understand
this evolution of paternal care through this, through there
being an increased certainty for human males that, that,
that Children that they raise with their um opposite
sex partner are theirs. Um And also the fact
that humans evolved in much more difficult environments than
the environments that are characterized by, by the great
apes that are alive today. And mothers really needed
help in the production of young, they needed help
from fathers and other family members if they were
going to be able to successfully raise young. And
that's another really important reason why we see paternal
investment in humans and not so much in the
other great ape species where mothers are much more
able to raise offspring without assistance from other individuals.
Mhm. So I've already talked several times about grandmothers
on the show. So I would like to ask
you specifically about this since as far as we
know, it was women who tended to move to
their husband's household when they married. I mean, why
is it that it is maternal grandmothers that tend
to invest more in their grandchildren than paternal grandmothers
and not the other way around considering that then
the Children would be living in their father's household.
Yeah, that's, that's a really interesting question. And it's
one that when, when I first started to learn
about these uh reproductive conflicts that prompted the evolution
of menopause. That was a question that I also
had as well because in some ways, you, your
default assumption is that the younger female has moved
to live with the husband's uh family. And so
the nearest available grandmother to help is gonna be
the paternal grandmother. So why isn't she, why are
paternal grandmothers less decisive for the survival of offspring
and for the fecundity of females than maternal grandmothers?
Um And it I asked Mike Can about this.
He is the guy who he's one of the
evolutionary biologists who has been very heavily involved in
developing the theoretical models on the evolution of menopause.
And he, his, he, his view was that the
model is correct. We fe we do see female
bias dispersal such that females are moving to live
with their husband's family and they're in closer proximity
to their mother-in-law than they are to their own
mother. But as long as they don't move too
far away, as long as that dispersal distance isn't
too far, then the maternal grandmother can still can
still manage to help her daughter um in rai
with raising offspring and anything that that entails. And
so I think in my mind, at least I'd
kind of always assumed that this dispersal was happening
over a really vast distance. And so, you know,
you're leaving home and that's it, you're never gonna
see them again. But I think probably the dis
the distances that we're talking about are not as
prohibitive for allowing maternal grandmothers to still be involved
in helping their daughters to raise young. And in
fact, there are some data showing that when the
distance moved by the younger female is far enough
such that their, their mother can no longer help,
then they, they actually experience reduced bund and reduced
survival of their offspring because they don't have that
assistance from their own mothers in producing young.
Yeah, it's interesting. I also have that idea that
when they moved, it was so far away that
perhaps maternal grandmothers wouldn't be able to help there.
And I was even asking myself if we could
talk about male fill of pater in humans, but
perhaps not.
I think we don't, I think basically, uh I'm
not an expert in this but the, as far
as we know, um I think our best estimates
are that dispersal in ancestral human populations was female
biased. And so, and I think the, the models
of the evolution of menopause and the reproductive conflicts
and how those are resolved through relatedness, asymmetries between
uh the paternal mother in law, the paternal grandmother
and the younger female makes sense under this framework
of female biased dispersal. So I think that, um
I guess, I don't know, maybe new data will
come and things will be overturned. But my, I,
at the moment, I sort of accept this consensus
that the dispersal in ancestral human populations was female
biased.
Right. So, I mean, but, but in the case
of grandfathers, do they play any role whatsoever? Why
is it that men have also such long lifespans
on average?
So there's um an evolutionary demographer called Rebecca Seer,
who's done lots of work on um who keeps
Children alive. That's the title of one of her
papers who keeps Children alive and based on meta
analysis of lots of different studies, um as you
might expect the most important person for keeping Children
alive in the first years of life is the
mother, fathers have a much less decisive role to
play in the survival of their offspring. The presence
of a maternal grandmother often has a positive effect,
but the presence of grandfathers is really not decisive
at all for keeping Children alive. And so the
inference um from these, from these studies is that
grandfathers aren't really doing that much. Um AT least
in these um in these studies for which we
have data, grandfathers aren't doing that much to keep
their grandchildren alive, to improve the survival of their,
of their grandchildren. And so yes, there is a,
a question of why do you know, why do
men get to then have this extended lifespan? And
I think one of the most obvious answers that
I've seen uh that makes sense is that a
man can still continue to accrue reproductive success quite
late into his life. Um And without a substantial
amount of investment, unlike, unlike women who have to,
you know, get pregnant and just stay a baby
and then um lactate after the baby is born,
the investment involved for a male is much, much
less. And so it could, it can simply be
like these opportunities to continue to accrue reproductive success,
can help to select um for a long lifespan
in men as well as in women.
Mhm. So moving from families, why is it that
it is so common from for humans to help
others they are unrelated to?
So, yeah, I mean, this is a really big
question and I guess whenever we ask a why
question in evolutionary biology, we have to always recognize
that there are two different, broadly speaking, two different
kinds of explanation that we could offer. So, on
the one hand, we can offer what we call
proximate level explanations and they're simply concerned with how
the behavior comes about what the motives are or
the maybe the physiological mechanisms that bring that behavior
about. And we can also ask um what we
call um Well, sorry, we can also provide what
we call ultimate level explanations. And those are more
concerned with the evolutionary significance of the behavior. And
so when we ask why humans help strangers, if
we were to offer proximate level explanations, we might
be in the realm of thinking about things like
warm glow, it feels good to help other people,
or maybe we have a norm, psychology. And in
the society that we live in, there's a norm
which dictates that you ought to help, you know,
help people if you can, even if you don't
know them. Um There, there are a bunch of
um proximate level explanations that you could offer to
explain why people might help others. And I really
don't think it's as simple as saying, here's the
reason there are, there are maybe, I don't know
25 or 30 different kinds of proximate level explanation.
Maybe more that you could offer to, to, to
that in answer to that question. If you want
to give an ultimate level explanation of why people
help. Well, broadly speaking, we would say that um
the tendency to help other individuals, if it has
any genetic basis would be under positive selection if
it increases the individual's inclusive fitness. So if it,
if it generates some benefits in terms of survival
or reproductive success, and there are a few evolutionary
routes by which that could be achieved, for example,
um if you help other individuals, you might improve
your reputation and then you might then improve your
standing or your social position, you might be more
likely to get helped, um, by other people when
you need it. Given that you have a reputation
for being a helpful person who is normally doing
the right thing for others, you might um, avoid
being punished by other people if you, if you
help in certain scenarios or if you don't defect
in certain scenarios. Um, THERE again, just like with
the proximate level of answers, there are, there are
multiple different routes by which a tendency to help
others could, could be reconciled with benefits at the
individual level. And you could see how it could
be under positive selection.
Mhm. So if one of people's concerns is their
reputation, what about when they perform good deeds that
are hidden from others? I mean, what do, why
do we do that? And what do we have
to gain from it?
So, one of the really important things to bear
in mind when we're thinking about things like why
does a human, why do people help other people?
Like I said, one, we can think about these
two different kinds of explanation which we call proximate
and ultimate. And often people don't often have to
be aware of the ultimate level um of the
ultimate function of the behavior for the behavior to
be under positive selection. And so, um if we
take a completely different example, just because sometimes it's
easier to think about something that's slightly different. If
you were to say why do people have sex?
Well, on a proximate level, people have sex because
they find it, um, you know, they enjoy it
or they desire to have it or they find,
you know, they find it subjectively rewarding. The ultimate
reason sex exists and the ultimate function of sex
is, or at least one ultimate function is to
produce offspring. It's a pretty direct means to increase
reproductive success. That doesn't mean that every time we
have sex we're kind of thinking about, I'm gonna
get reproductive success. Now, like people, the proximate and
the ultimate reasons why behavior exists can be completely
separate. And often in our mind, we're not even
aware of the ultimate reason why we do something.
And so if you say something like why do
people give anonymously well for many people helping others
or donating to charity or giving in an anonymous
way feels very subjectively rewarding. It's a phenomenon that
economists have called the warm glow of giving. And
it, you know, makes you feel all fuzzy and
nice inside to know that you've helped somebody. Um
And that fuzzy warm feeling is evolution's way of
getting you to do something that on average is
in your long term interest that on average might
be expected to result in reputation benefits or any
other host of benefits that might occur because of
you performing a helpful action. And if, if occasionally
that doesn't happen, that doesn't mean that the whole
strategy is, is under negative selection. It's a evolution
works on averages, it works on average outcomes. Um
And sometimes the reason why we do something is
really quite different to the evolutionary reason that that
behavior exists if that makes
sense. Yes, it makes perfect sense. But in the
book, you also talk about how people tend to
be uncharitable toward those who do good deeds. So,
I mean, why is that
then? Yeah. So that's another thing that I always
wanted to come to. So thanks for asking that
question. So one of the unusual things about human
psychology is that we don't just, we're not stuck
with observing behavior and having to assume that the
behaviors that we observe, that the intentions and the
outcomes are always perfectly aligned. So humans have this
very sort of sophisticated form of cognition that some
psychological theory of mind that allows us to look
under the hood. When we see somebody doing something,
for example, giving to charity, we can look under
the hood and we can, we can actually entertain
the possibility that the reason that someone's doing something
might be different to the reason that they, that
they are trying to signal. So for example, when
someone gives to charity, we we know that often
doing charitable acts can result in reputation benefits. And
so when we see someone doing a charitable thing,
we can also ask ourselves, well, is the reason
the person is giving to charity? Is it because
they want to help that beneficiary or is it
because they actually want to improve their own image
or their own appearance or how they look to
other people? And this kind of skepticism is a
uniquely human trait. I think it's one that we
don't share with any other nonhuman species and it
actually can result in some quite strange outcomes which
is that often doing good doesn't lead to looking
good because people can be suspicious of the reason
why you're doing it. And if we suspect that
people are acting with these calculated or self serving
motives in mind, then we frequently withhold reputation benefits.
And we don't, um, we don't afford that individual,
the higher status that you might normally expect to
result from doing these charitable things. And so in
some ways, you can then get into these counter
cycles of individuals actually hiding their altruistic behavior, for
example, by donating anonymously or, um, something like that
so that they don't invite this skepticism or this
suspicion from other people. There's actually a really lovely
quote, um from Oscar Wilde, which I think really
sums it up nicely, which is, it's something like
the nicest feeling in the world is to donate
anonymously, but have somebody else find out about it.
And the reason that it's the nicest feeling in
the world, it's because of course, if they think
you're doing it anonymously, then all the skepticism that
results from looking under the hood is vastly reduced
because, uh, the, you know, there's no, it seems
far less calculated when you do it sort of
anonymously.
So, but taking into account all of the benefits
we might get from helping other people talking from
approximate level, perhaps just feeling good and ultimately, perhaps
even increasing our fitness. Can we say that people
are really altruistic or is helping behavior? Ultimately selfish?
I think on a proximate psychological level, lots of
what you would call helping behavior or altruistic behavior
is psychologically altruistic. It's, it's motivated from a genuine
desire to help other people or a genuine enjoyment
from, you know, doing the right thing. And so
I, and I think this is where often I
run into, um or I get challenged by people
because they think that you're trying to take the
altruism out of altruism in a way by suggesting
that um helping behavior can ultimately be explained in
terms of benefits to the helpful individual. People will
often mistakenly assume that that means that all helpful
behavior is performed in a calculated manner and with
those benefits in mind. And that's not at all
what an evolutionary perspective would say. So the evolutionary
perspective to, to allow us for the fact that
helping behavior can be psychologically pure can be very,
very genuinely altruistic with no real calculated um uh
desire to improve one's own position, supporting it. But
that doesn't change the fact that those, those psychological
motives, those proximate motives have probably been selected for
because ultimately in an evolutionary sense, performing helpful behaviors
or being co-operative is often the best way to
ensure evolutionary success. And so, yes, I think altruism
a lot of the time is uh can be
understood in terms of self interest. If what you
mean is the self interest, the gene's own selfish
interest. But I don't think that that means that
all altruism is knowingly or calculatedly selfish.
So, could you tell us about interdependence?
Yeah. So I think, I mean, I mentioned at
the start that I think this is sort of
a a neglected mechanism for supporting cooper operation relative
to something like reciprocal altruism. Um Interdependence is just
the idea that you have a stake in your
partner's well being or fitness more strictly speaking. Um
I illustrate the idea of interdependence in the book
using a toy example, which is imagine if you
were in a rowing boat with um one other
person and the boat springs a leak and the
boat's filling up with water and you both need
to bail out the water to, you know, in
order for the boat not to sink. Now, if
you, if you were the kind of uh prepared
individual on the boat and you brought one chocolate
bar, but your friend didn't have a chocolate bar
with them, it could actually be in your own
interest to share that chocolate with your friend to
the extent that that allows them to keep on
bailing out the boat. If we assume that both
of you are needed to bail out the boat
in order to stop it sinking, then you suddenly
become really interdependent and it can be in your
own best interest to help your interdependent partner. Even
if there's no expectation of reciprocity at that time,
simply because your partner, your own survival or your
own well being is highly dependent on your partner's
presence and your partner's um being there. And so
this is the idea of interdependence and for many
issues that live in groups or that have stable
social interactions or repeated social interactions with the same
individuals, it probably makes quite a lot of sense
to think about these interaction partners as being interdependent
rather than simply being to individuals that w that
support cooper operation through um a highly dogmatic form
of reciprocal altruism like tit for tat and the
difference between those two things is that in tit
for tat, it only benefits me to help you
if I think you're gonna help me in return.
And if I help you and you don't help
me, then I've just wasted my investment. If we're
interdependent, it can benefit me to help you even
if you don't help me in return. And I
think that that idea of it um unconditional helping
within these sort of established relationships is much more
in line with what we see in nature. And
these relationships probably are often much more interdependent than
we have previously um assumed.
And and why do we care so much about
what other people think of us?
Well, for humans, I think that we are all
very, very sensitive to our image or our reputation.
And some of the reasons for that are that
individuals that gain a good reputation are often more
likely to be chosen as interaction partners. So if
you in experimental settings and also in real world
settings, the most generous individuals are often the people
that um in an experiment, people say they want
to choose them as a partner in real world
scenarios, those often occupy more central social network positions,
they have more social capital. Um And they're also
more likely to receive support themselves if they fall
ill or if they are unable to meet their
needs. For whatever reason, the individuals that have accrued,
a good reputation are more likely to receive help
from others when they need it. And I think
there are uh this um this sensitivity to reputation
can be explained in terms of our dependence on
one another and our dependence on our social connections
to, to survive and to, to meet our daily
requirements. And for sure, like the humans are massively
concerned with our reputation and we don't really see
much evidence of that in any other species apart
from the cleaner fish um system that I've worked
on with red one Bahari. So I tell you,
a bit more about it.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. I mean, I have them on
the show and we talked a little bit about
that. But yeah, please go ahead.
So it's kind of again, it's this idea of
the behavioral destination and the journey because cleaner fish
do show concern for reputation, but they do the
cognitive journey they take to exhibit this concern for
reputation is very different to the cognitive journey that
humans use to show concern for reputation. So briefly,
um, cleaner fish live on coral reefs and they
offer a cleaning service to their clients, which involves
removing parasites from the surface of the skin. But
there's a conflict between the cleaners and the clients
because the cleaners would actually prefer to eat living
tissues, mucus and scales um and not to eat
the active parasites. Now, some of the clients that
a cleaner fish interacts with have a large home
range and that means that they have access to
multiple cleaning stations within their home range and that
means that they can afford to be fussy. So
if they, if they go to a cleaning station
and they arrive there and they see something ending
badly, they see the cleaner fish being chased by
the current clients or they see the current clients
swimming away very quickly, then the fussy client will,
can think, ok, I won't stay here. I'll go
some, I'll go to this other place that I
know about this other cleaning station. Strangely enough, Cleaner
Fish seem to be aware when they're being watched
by these, what we call fussy or visitor clients.
And they are actually more cooper or they offer
a better service to their current clients when they're
being watched by the fussy or the visitor client.
And this demonstrates a rudimentary concern for reputation in
clean official caring about what other individuals think. And
of course, in the cleaner fish, the cognition that
supports this is not the ability to take perspective,
to understand what the client is thinking or to
impute beliefs to the client or anything like this.
It can simply be learned through trial and error
that if I do, if I cheat, then those
kinds of clients always swim away. So therefore, I
won't, I'll X parasites and um they learn through
trial and error or through associative learning what behaviors
bring about the rewards that they're seeking. And so
it just again, it's this idea of thinking about
the same behaviors but different cognition supporting those those
same sort of behavioral outcomes.
So at the same time, we also have lots
of social comparison. I mean, we compare ourselves to
others a lot. And I would imagine that particularly
in circumstances where there's lots of inequality that would
have negative psychological impacts on people. So I, I
mean, in what way is the social comparison affect
our lives?
Yeah. Again, it's a super interesting question and I
think it's one where there's not actually, there's, there's,
I wouldn't say there's a consensus yet in the
field as to whether social comparison is uniquely human
or not. So one way that social comparison can
manifest is as a concern for fairness or disliking
getting rewards that are less than what another individual
gets. Um And in the lab, you can measure
this by asking whether individuals will refuse a reward
if a partner gets something better. And this can
be a test of what we call inequity aversion.
Now, we know that young Children are usually very
averse to inequity and anyone who's spent any time
with a young child will have heard them shout.
Oh, that's not fair. And this kind of tendency
to appreciate what's fair and what's not fair comes
online at about four or five years old and
Children really start to be able to be sensitive
to, I'm getting one thing and you're getting four
things and that's not fair and they will actually
refuse. They will sacrifice their one sticker or their
one sweet to prevent the partner from getting more
than them. When people have done similar studies with
nonhuman primates and with other animals, the results are
much more mixed. And in my view, I don't
think that the evidence is very strong to suggest
that other species have a concern for fairness. And
I think that many of the results in this
field are more consistent with much simpler explanations of
um of of the cognition that supports rejecting unfair
outcomes. For example, it can be due to frustration
at seeing something you want, that you can't get
or having your expectations violated. Like you see that
one individual gets four, but you get one. And
so you have it, it's not necessarily a social
comparison that we're seeing in, in other species in
the same way that we, that we see in
humans. Um And I think this concern for fairness
and this meritocratic psychology, if you like this idea
that things ought to be fair. And that uh
for example, if we work together to achieve a
joint outcome, then we ought to share the spoils
of that outcome where I shouldn't just take everything
for myself and leave you with nothing, right? This,
this is the kind of um psychology and the
kind of behavior that a concern for fairness can
support. And it's really a point where we really
see quite strong divergence between humans and uh in
particular chimpanzees where for example, even human Children who
work together to get a reward will then voluntarily
split that reward with the partner that they worked
to get the reward with. Whereas in chimpanzees, if
they, they will work together to get a reward,
if they have to, but you never see the
in the one individual then giving half to the
other one that helped it. If they can monopolize
the reward, they will monopolize it for themselves. And
so you can see how this non meritocratic um
principle could be a real impediment to collaboration because
in a way, what's the point of working with
you on a task? If we at the end
of it, you, I, you just keep everything for
yourself and I don't get anything. And so I
think this kind of psychology, this c this concern
for fairness which you call social comparison is all
part of the same thing. But it's a really
crucial foundation of our collaborative natures actually, and our,
our ability to work together to achieve joint success
and to motivate individuals to work together, to achieve
joint success. And I think that is a real
point of divergence between humans and the other great
apes.
So talking about unfairness, this ability, we have to
join together and rebel against tyrannical leaders, for example,
is it uniquely human? Do we also find it
in other great apes, for example? And if not,
uh in what ways does it allow for us
to affect social structures that we don't really find
in other great apes?
I think among the apes, it's quite unique. It's
what Christopher Berm has called the reverse dominance hierarchy
where um individuals resist the actions of dominant or
big shot um individuals and instead they work together
to prevent any selfish minority from gaining an unfair
advantage. Um And this is part of what why
human societies are often described as being egalitarian. Unlike
many of the other great ape societies that are
often much more hierarchical, much more despotic and where
an alpha male often gets a great, much greater
share of reproduction than the other males in the
group. How having said that I don't think it's
unique to humans because there are, I mean, when
we, as I said, at the start, the reason
why I started the book by thinking about co-operation
inside our bodies is that I said that some
of the common principles that we saw in the
evolution of co-operation to form individuals, we would also
see at different levels or different scales of um
evolution. And one of those general principles is this
idea of the collective pulling against the might of
any selfish entity that tries to gain an unfair
advantage. And one place where we see that principle
in action is actually inside our bodies where all
the genes form what has been called a parliament
of the genes where they, they all work to
together in some ways to prevent the actions of
any selfish genetic element or any selfish gene that
tries to over replicate itself relative to the others.
They were the the rest of the genome works
together to prevent any of those selfish entities from
having their way and from disrupting the um the
the stability of the collective in some social insect
species. You see workers who work together to collectively
police the actions of any single worker who tries
to lay eggs in the society. So sometimes worker
ants or worker bees can lay under fertilized eggs
that will develop into males. But the other workers
in the society will often eat those eggs, they'll
cannibalize them. And that's called worker policing. And again,
you see the might of the collective at work
in holding the kind of the interests of selfish
entities, selfish genes, selfish individuals in check. And so
I actually think that that pattern of the collective
a bit like a tug of war. The collective
on one end of the rope pulling against the
in the individual selfish elements. On the other end
is a real common theme that we see at
all levels of life and the transitions to greater
complexity, the evolutionary transitions to greater complexity occur when
that collective is able to overwhelm the interests of
the selfish, uh the the the sort of selfish
entities.
So we're reaching our time limit. So, uh so
let me just ask you one last question with
all of this in mind. I mean, with what
we know about the evolution of human cooper operation
and how it works? Is it possible for us
to foster uh large scale cooper operation? Like for
example, nowadays, we have issues to tackle like climate
change, which demand, I mean, international Co Ordination. Is
there something that you wrote about in your book
or uh somewhere else about human cooper operation that
we can use with that with that goal in
mind.
So I think that many of the massive global
problems that we face today are problems of failed
co-operation and they are problems that require us to
co-operate at global scales. And it's not obvious that
this is something that we're especially good at. So
we're what one problem with global cooper operation in
a way is that it's constantly at risk of
being undermined by co-operation at lower levels and co-operation
that's easier to achieve. So, for example, um nepotism
and corruption and bribery are all forms of local
co-operation that are quite natural to us in some
ways, nepotism is helping us family corruption or things
like that or can be helping your friends. I
mean, these are forms of cooper operation and they
are, they come much more easily to us in
some respects than cooperating at a global scale with
people that we don't know that we might never
meet. Um And so I don't think it's a
given that we will necessarily be able to resolve
the global challenges that we face. And I certainly
am not gonna sit here and tell you that
I have the answers. But II, I also don't
think, I don't think it's totally out of our
grasp to do it. But I think it, it
in it will involve us learning how to co-operate
at a scale that we've never really before managed
to do effectively. And so I guess it's for
me, I think it's still really an open question
how the human story really ends and what, whether
we managed to over climate disaster and, and you
know, o overcome future pandemics that we're going to
experience and things like this, I think we can
do it. Um But whether we will do it,
I think is up to us.
OK. So, uh the book is again, the Social
Instinct of cooper operation shaped the world. Uh Where
can people find you on the internet?
Um I am probably most easy to find on
Twitter where I my handle is at Nicola Rajani.
My full name, I have a website called the
Social Evolution and Behavior Lab and that's at UCL
University College London. And yeah, you can find me
there.
OK. So it's been a real pleasure to talk
to you, Nicola. Thank you for coming on the
show. Thanks so much. Hi guys. Thank you for
watching this interview. Until the end. I would just
like to ask you if you can to please
consider supporting the show for it to keep running.
You will find links to my Patreon page and
also to paypal in the description box of this
interview and amount even just $1 per month will
already be a great help. Otherwise, and if you
like what I'm doing, please share the interview. Leave
a like and hit the subscription button. The issue
is brought to you by N Lights learning and
development. Done differently. Check their website at N lights.com.
And finally, I would like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and papal supporters,
Kenen Litzke and Blanchett Bears and Las for S
Fredericks Ricardo Vladimir Craig Healey, Adam Kel Olaf, Alec
Jonathan Wiesel Jacob Wipe Matthew Whitten Bed, Arno Wolf,
Tim Hollis, Henri Alenius John Connors Paulina Baron Philip
for Connolly Jerry Mueller, Herbert Gins, Ruth Gervase Bo
Wear M Beger Goldstein. Then Dimetri Robert Windegger Ruin,
ASIO Arthur Kz Mark Nevs Colin Holbrook, Susan Pinker
Thomas Trumble, Bernard Seus Pablo, San Simon Columbus, George
Pina Phil Cavanagh, Cory Clark, Mark Blythe Roberto Nws
Mi Stormer Eric Neumann Samuel Andreev Diag nuns, Bernard
Eni, Alexander Dun Bauer, Amarie Hickson, Fergal, Ken Evan
Boden H Herzog John Ross, Jonathan Libran Oslo Bullet,
Nathan Lean Stanton T Samuel Correa, Eric Ians, Mark
Smith, Jw Juan We Tom Hummel David Sloan Wilson,
Yasa Desa Rau Ivan Solo, Roma Roach, Dmitri Grigoriev,
Diego London, Correa, Tom Roth Jank Punter, Adana Rosman
Charlotte Bli Nicole Barbaro, Adam Hunt Palo Stasi Nele
Bach, Catherine and Patrick Tobin. All Ortiz Guy Madison
Gary G Elman. Jean liars L A Adrian Yagi,
Nick, Golden Paul Tolentino. Jean Bobos, Jules Price Edward
Hall. My producers is our web, Jim Frank Luca
stank, Ian Gilligan, Sergio, Guan Lo and Tom Venning
Curtis Dixon Jean Linear Benedict Mueller, Vegi Sardo France
and Ian Bachan. And my executive producers, Michelle Rozsi,
Rosie Jim Spratt and Matthew Lavender. Thank you for
all.